[Music]
bunting balloons and a well-stocked bar
the key ingredients for a traditional
british street party
and of course the rain but here in
brimsfield in gloucestershire they were
determined nothing would dampen the mood
her majesty
is an inspiration
she
guides us she leads us
and
we have
a queen who is unique
around the country people gathered in
preston there was free food on offer to
make sure people struggling with the
cost of living were able to join the
party
providing the food from the guru nanak
gurudwara stall here but also we want
people to experience the new perspective
of a cultural heritage in preston we're
going through difficult times now the
hardship that people are facing is
important that those people who are
finding it difficulty for no
circumstances of their own type of thing
i don't feel excluded from being part of
the platinum jubilee celebrations
in morecambe the party went on and on
a record for the longest street party
after two years of covet people happy to
be together
the town's coming live again
we suffered a lot um
but yeah it's just this is a great
excuse to get rid back out and enjoy it
among the feast a trifle made by jenny
who remembers the queen's coronation
i've loved her since i was a little girl
my mum and i used to do scrapbooks
and
my husband actually is taking
photographs of all this and we're going
to do a scrapbook and here we go they're
off and racing we know her majesties
love of horse racing
and corgis so what better way to
celebrate than a corgi race the surreal
spectacle enjoyed by supporters at
musclebra racecourse near edinburgh
corgi georgie the eventual winner
back in brimsfield there was an
appearance of sorts from the younger
royals and a toast to her majesty
right across the country we've seen how
people have embraced these jubilee
celebrations a chance for communities to
come together to honor the queen's
remarkable achievement
a moment in history marked in true
british style
[Music]
becky johnson sky news gloucestershire